I want you to notice the features that
make it what it is it's a sine graph we
know what sine looks like but it's been
changed in two ways what are the two
changes
how would you overlies with changing
position stop with an acid diarrhea see
this changes the frequency if I wanted
to change the amplitude how would I
change it I would put it out in front
over here or could have amplitude ended
up down feeding I would put a number
dividing lifeline this Greek is why is
an opportunity through so that changes
our frequency in it more frequent or
left free more frequent
that means from north 360 I'm going to
get two full copies of this thing not
just one okay so far so group we know
there's a frequency change what's the
other change what's the work is a
horizontal shift which because it's um a
trig function we also have special
benzene in this relationship we also
call it a phase shift okay
so then the phase shift there's a
frequency change but here's the trick
these two interact with each other in a
way that maybe is a little bit
surprising let me show you how I'm going
to grasp it two different ways I will
end up going to say grass both win but
I'm going to show you two different
methods to repression okay so the first
thing I want you to do is do you sure a
regular side rest for me just draw me a
regular 1/2 mile to 360
regular cyber now he is our regular
Center I George it joy from zero 350 and
the reason why 360 is such a common
directory 16 such a common domain to
choose and because that means you get to
the end of the period it's also called
one full cycle of rest yes the most the
most recent file you should mind like
one April page yeah yeah yeah I guess so
here we go looks beautiful
I've got my intercepts in there but I
need this one I've got my amplitude we
already discussed that that's not going
to change in this question so so far so
good
ok now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to apply the modifications there in here
one is time well I'm going to do them in
different orders you're too early
let's do the spaceship first 90 degrees
in what direction to the right ok we
know it's a bit funny you've got to get
you some readings backwards so see how
this works intercept using a zero
well now let's put 360 in here and 180
then when you begin it is going to be
here actually see if they move 90
degrees to done right so far so good
when I think about this turning point of
here that usually occurs at 90 degrees
but in fact I have shifted it right here
is the light so now it's a 180 okay and
then you could fill in the rest of it ok
we're just
we do that
so this is the shape that you have what
do you think are you comfortable with
that
look one station is I'm talking for
examining needs a little work a little
more yeah okay I'm happy with that now
if I just before we leave off we should
on because we're using all these
different support graphs to get to this
one I'm going to label all the Victorian
points available but this at least this
way I'll know exactly which ones which
this is line of sine of X minus 20 all
I've done is the phase shift by the way
that's not the only way you could label
this graph what does it look like if I
didn't tell you this what would you say
that this one doesn't it look like an
upside down code it is an upside down so
just as a side note you might have not
noticed that is also equal to negative
cos x that's a visual plug bit it true x
you can come back that I can catch you
later on what I did my face shift now
what I'm going to do and I'm going to
forget that this diet is I'm going to
start with this and then I'm going to
apply the frequency change right so see
how that's wonderful copy well from
north of 360 now I'm going to get two
copies of Miss gone sorry sir
we cannot pick carefully from her this
means that from a period it used to be
360 degrees the new period is 108 now
wait a second and this is the critical
point and this is the counterintuitive
if you've taken this whole rap and you
squeeze it in so take off the horizontal
wrist now but what was the intercepts
the X intercepts for this graph what
whether it's just look at the graph
higher then 90 and 270 but we've just
insane that everything on the graph is
going to compress to half the space so
they will not be at night
and to 70 anymore this one is going to
get squashed into 45 and this one will
get squashed into a hundred and
thirty-five yes so over here paper which
one of it this finish my god
this thing here and I put my ninety
degrees in there so that I can get my
scale right
that means this is 45 nooses 135 yes so
here's the shame of it
looks like this my guess
I miss the jumping idea okay now that's
one copy and because it's periodic I
just had to redraw spin these roots at
45 and 135 we're going to get new copies
over CR seems to me 225 and 315 okay
because the rich used to be everyone has
a neat but now they're every crease in
the double every 90 degrees
that makes 225 and 315 within six okay
this is the graph this is sine 2x minus
90 degrees now I want you to take off
your student hat for a moment and I want
you to put on your teacher hat your
market app okay now that you know this
is what the graph is supposed to look
like what do you think is the most
common error students make when they see
this and fail to grasp this what do you
think their graph instead everything
what are you okay so you're talking
about like we can go to access a little
earlier so you mean like movie shape up
okay you do some tools to do the shape
up because they confuse which direction
they're shifting it they're like I know
there's a shift but I don't know which
way it makes me that that does happens
but not as often as when students look
at this number and they say I know what
that means it means I learn to shift to
the right 90 degrees so they say their
first intercept is going to be at 90
degrees but it's not it's not in
Nigerian it doesn't shift my teeth
actually it shifted 45 do you see why
point fiver
what was it about this interaction to
make point life do you remember it was
the Harvick wasn't it was the squeezing
in right so this guy doesn't just sort
of operate on donors he actually has to
play ball with this guy and that's
confusing to students okay so here's
what I'm going to do now I said to you
I'm going to graph it in two different
ways students often get confused they
say well how am I supposed to remember
to do the phase the horizontal shift
first and then do the frequency change
how am I supposed to remember which one
comes back because if you do this
squeeze it in and then move it 90
degrees
you're warm you get the wrong grass let
me show you how to do it so now parallel
to these are going to draw two more bits
of action to get to the same rap
in the first instance I face uses and
then I change the frequency this time
let's change the frequency first so
instead of rounding that I'm going to
graph y subscribe to equity this is not
too hard it's the original graph but two
copies should not defeat you that makes
it let's go ahead and tell this to copy
what do you think
alright you're happy with that except
that that would normally be 720 squashed
everything in so this is 3/16 I'll have
to put the rest of the retailer up
important 19 182 7 so far so good
there's a frequency change take five and
keep the key right I'm actually going to
put this one in a new color why don't
you go to show you and I really didn't
unless my grandchildren when I moved
from this guy which looks like this so
the new one that 90 degree shift it
actually has to get shared across both
excellence let me say that again you
shift my degrees to the right okay but
it's like there are two x's there that
both need to be shifted right so each
one only get individually shifted 45
here's how I write it this is sine of 2
lakh per day right in order to shift
that X I'm actually shifting at 45
degrees because look if the X is getting
doubled so is the shift do you see that
okay so when you see it in its original
form like this now that actual shift the
real shift is disguised right how much
is X being change it's really being
changed by 45 degrees right
I'll here look like is mighty but there
are two eggs in here before names we
change so that nine degrees as it were
if shared across person by the same
token if I change the question if I made
this say three X minus nine degrees
how much is the actual shift going to be
30 degrees if I made it six X minus 90
it would only go 15 degrees and whatever
it might happen to be because these two
things interact with each other so now
that I've got this on here how do I get
to the actual graph that I need I'm
going to shift to the right 45 so what
have I got here I said that this is 90
and this is zero right so now I'm going
to start the zero at 45 and then this
one is forward to 135 and then this one
is forward to 225 and so on right and
then I'll just complete
there's that orange part has been routed
to the black 45° just like you told me
to and then I need an extra bit over
here to fill in the gap which as a
relief looks exactly like what we've got
the other way it doesn't actually matter
which one you do first so long as you go
to power to do each one in the right
order